radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green is
complaining that her congressional
salary is too low especially because she
has to work most of the year if you can
imagine that becoming a member of
Congress has made my life miserable I
made a lot more money before I got here
I've lost money since I've gotten here
most people have to work most of the
year and most people don't make 174 000
a year in fact Marjorie Taylor Green's
hundred and seventy four thousand dollar
salary puts her in the 92nd percentile
among adults working full-time meaning
she makes more than 92 percent of adults
working full-time and less than only
eight percent of adults working
full-time and she still has to work
almost the entire year I don't know why
poor white people in Georgia vote for
this woman but this is not going to make
her any more relatable that I can assure
you